i
[Música]
no para la escalada de violencia entre
gaza e israel en la noche del viernes el
ejército israelí lanzó cinco bombardeos
a casa doce personas de una misma
familia murieron una decena de
ambulancias egipcias entraron a casa
para trasladar a los heridos al menos
144 personas en su mayoría palestinos
han muerto en los 6 días de conflicto
y mientras colombia atraviesa una de sus
peores crisis sociales y políticas donde
cada día se conocen más casos de abusos
por parte de la fuerza policial la
pandemia nueva tregua del país superó
las 80 mil muertes por hoy 19 y no
consigue superar la tercera ola con un
sistema hospitalario colapsado en varias
ciudades
los chilenos eligen este sábado y mañana
los 155 asambleístas que redactarán la
nueva constitución para reemplazar la
que está desde la dictadura militar de
augusto pinochet y que será además la
primera paritaria en el mundo uno de los
logros del estallido social de octubre
del año 2019 también se elegirán
alcaldes concejales y gobernadores
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
en france 24 si blanco como siempre un
gusto acompañarlos esta mañana
comenzamos en israel donde aún no se ve
una señal de diálogo en la escalada
bélica sin precedentes en los últimos
siete años entre el grupo hamas e israel
gaza vivió una de sus peores noches
desde el lunes el ejército israelí
realizó cerca de 5 bombardeos en la
franja dejando a 12 personas muertas
pertenecientes a una misma familia
aumentando así a 136 fallecidos solo en
casa y 8 en israel mientras tanto
decenas de ambulancias del vecino egipto
entraron a casa para trasladar a los
heridos en tel aviv ya se encuentra el
enviado especial de eeuu que irían para
mediar en este conflicto aunque sin
interlocución directa con hamás
considera al grupo terrorista por su
gobierno todo ello a pesar de que el
primer ministro israelí benjamín
netanyahu dijo este viernes que su
ofensiva no ha terminado todavía ayer un
nuevo frente de civiles en las ciudades
de cisjordania se enfrentaron con la
policía israelí
[Música]
cuando estallaron los enfrentamientos en
jerusalén cuando los disturbios se
extendieron a la franja de gaza y luego
se extendieron las ciudades de todo
israel cisjordania mantuvo la calma pero
ahora se ha creado un tercer frente en
hebrón en ramala y naplusa cientos de
palestinos se enfrentaron con el
ejército israelí para los manifestantes
todos los campos de lucha están
conectados
a la ciudad de naplusa sus aldeas y
campamentos respondieron al llamado el
llamado de jerusalén y el llamado de gas
a la plus a sus aldeas y campamentos se
levantaron por los martines de jerusalén
y los de gaza
los palestinos tienen sus razones en
esta lucha la amenaza de que varias
familias palestinas sean desalojadas de
sus hogares en jerusalén-este en una
batalla judicial por la propiedad de la
tierra en la que están construidas sus
casas los enfrentamientos en la mezquita
de al-aqsa también conocida como el
monte del templo este 15 de mayo es una
fecha muy sensible se conmemora el
aniversario de la nakba o la catástrofe
en árabe y que hace referencia a la
creación del estado de israel en 1948
seguida de la primera guerra
árabe-israelí y la expulsión de miles de
palestinos de sus tierras los disturbios
actuales pueden dar lugar a más
enfrentamientos la lucha es la más
violenta que se ha registrado en los
últimos siete años el bombardeo israelí
a objetivos de hamas en la franja de
gaza ha causado decenas de muertes de
civiles y una destrucción generalizada
mientras tanto cerca de dos mil misiles
han sido disparados por hamas contra
israel matando también a varios civiles
en una escalada de la que no hay
indicios de su cese
cambiamos ahora de información y nos
vamos hasta colombia donde continúan las
protestas y el descontento hacia el
gobierno del presidente iván duquet
ahora los jóvenes muestran su ira por un
caso de violencia sexual señalando a la
policía como responsable después se
conocieron al menos 16 denuncias de
casos de acoso durante estos días de
protestas multitudinarias entretanto en
las últimas horas otro joven murió en
una jornada de graves disturbios en la
ciudad de popayán las manifestaciones se
han cobrado la vida de al menos 42
personas según la defensoría del pueblo
toda esta crisis social y política en
medio de la tercera ola de contagios en
el país que ya superan los 80 mil
fallecidos desde el inicio de la
pandemia y que tiene a los centros
hospitalarios colapsados en varias
ciudades de la nación
en un momento de altísima convulsión
social colombia superó los 80 mil
fallecidos por kobe 19 tras reportar 490
muertes este viernes el país atraviesa
la tercera ola la más mortal desde el
inicio de la pandemia en el último mes
se reportaron casi medio millón de casos
y más de 13 mil decesos las unidades de
cuidados intensivos siguen al borde del
colapso en bogotá están al 94 por ciento
de ocupación mientras que en medellín y
cali alcanzan el 99 y el 95 por ciento
respectivamente ellas se están viendo
algunas personas que están falleciendo
sin recibir la atención en una unidad de
cólera intensivo estando los servicios
de urgencias no pudiendo recibir la
atención de un equipo especializado y
tampoco el confort se conectará un
ventilador mecánico que también es
indispensable para este tipo de
situaciones en la etapa aguda
precisamente la alcaldesa de bogotá
claudia lópez anunció que dio positivo
para el virus
los médicos me han informado que tengo
una prueba psd positiva y aunque todos
mis signos vitales están afortunadamente
bien solo tengo un poquito de malestar y
mucho cansancio el 8% de la población
recibió el fármaco contra el cob y 19
pero sólo el 5% está completamente
vacunado en un país de casi 50 millones
de habitantes las restricciones para
frenar los contagios divergen en cada
departamento sin embargo las
aglomeraciones son inevitables en pleno
paro nacional pero de hecho la inmensa
mayoría de personas manifiesta con
tapabocas y entre los reclamos de los
manifestantes destaca la retirada de la
reforma de la salud y el acceso
universal a una asistencia sanitaria de
calidad y las elecciones de este fin de
semana en chile son históricas eligen a
quienes redactarán la nueva constitución
del país que reemplazará el texto
vigente desde la dictadura de augusto
pinochet por primera vez se elegirán a
candidatos de sus diez pueblos
originarios que tienen reservados 17
escaños entre los 155 cupos para quienes
harán una nueva carta magna en minutos
se abrirán las urnas para estos comicios
que durarán 2
como medida preventiva para evitar
aglomeraciones durante la pandemia y
además porque se trata de la mayor
cantidad de candidatos en una elección
de su historia son 16 mil 67 730 que se
representan además en otras tres
elecciones las de alcaldes concejales y
gobernadores en france 24 acompañamos a
una de las candidatas de su campaña
electoral la historia de nuestra
corresponsal
patricia luna
tengo 24 soy estudiante de derecho yo
fui presidente a la federación de
estudiantes la universidad de chile fui
la primera mujer trans en ocupar ese
cargo
emilia sneijder es uno de los casi 1.300
candidatos en chile para conformar la
convención constituyente la misión de
los 155 que resulten elegidos será poner
fin en el país a una de las más robustas
herencias de la dictadura su actual
constitución
desde esa experiencia de hacer grupos
históricamente excluidos de la política
las personas trans las mujeres los
movimientos sociales podemos aportar a
repensar la democracia en chile para
construir una mejor democracia más
profunda más directa más deliberativa
paritaria como el proceso constituyente
que vamos a tener en chile que el
primero para compañía en el mundo post
era en el movimiento feminista en chile
que se tomó las universidades y los
titulares del mundo en 2018 la lucha de
emilia visibiliza también la realidad
trans en un chile aún muy conservador en
ciertos sectores sociales queremos darle
a toda la discusión constitucional una
perspectiva feminista y desde las
disidencias sexuales no poner algunos
artículos sino tener una perspectiva
transversal desde allí
tras la suspensión de las elecciones
previstas para el 11 de abril pasado sin
apoyo económico de grupos poderosos su
mayor fortaleza está en conquistar la
calle puerta a puerta y en su bagaje
como líder social presente en múltiples
luchas chile- nuevamente se queda abajo
de garantizar un derecho que es
fundamental
a niños y adolescencia que la educación
sexual integral emilia que los últimos
cartuchos para tratar de convertirse en
una de las voces que haga historia al
dejar atrás la constitución de 1980 uno
de los últimos legados del dictador
augusto pinochet y construir un nuevo
mapa de ruta para un chile más justo
digno e igualitario tenemos que seguir
hablando traficando esos saberes que no
han llegado de una sexualidad libre
disidente loca y todas las cosas que no
buscan a nosotros
de esta manera llegamos al final de la
informativa en france24 continúen con
nosotros para más actualizaciones
noticias muy buen día
[Música]
todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar de mujeres en